[Music]
what if the universe is an illusion what
if your reality is not what it seems to
be what if you are just a
two-dimensional projection stretched on
the surface of a black hole
and what does a black hole have to do
with all this this is what if and here's
what would happen if you lived inside a
hologram I know what you think this
isn't real how can we live in a hologram
if everything around us is 3-dimensional
well prepare yourself for a big reality
check because this unified theory can
explain everything
about the fundamental laws of our
existence the holographic principle we
talked about it a little in the episode
where a black hole deleted the universe
you may want to watch that one again
because of all places the holographic
principle starts in a black hole when
you eat say a bagel your mass increases
by the mass of that bagel with your mass
increased your volume grows and so does
your surface area for a black hole it's
different it's only the surface area and
not the volume that increases with every
bite it's like the swallowed matter or
energy doesn't make it inside the black
hole but rather gets stuck to its
surface or like a view instead of eating
the bagel just taped it to the outside
of your stomach
black holes themselves are
three-dimensional but their contents can
be projected on their two-dimensional
surface and that gave scientists the
idea of the holographic world you me and
everything else in the universe is made
up of atoms and molecules atoms and
molecules are made up of smaller
subatomic particles and those particles
in turn are made up of something even
smaller the information about their
state in time and in space these
particles are so small that our eyes
can't detect them we just know they're
there and we know they don't answer to
the classical laws of physics it's up to
quantum mechanics to
interpret their nature one of the ways
to understand the smallest fundamental
particles is through the string theory
the string theory is purely theoretical
and the mathematics behind it is
complicated
nobody has ever solved it yet but maybe
we can change the rules a little bit if
you're trying to solve a complicated
problem you can map all the volume of
the universe across its boundary like a
hologram the nature of the problem
changes because for the two-dimensional
universe we don't need to count quantum
gravity in that turns the nearly
impossible to crack mathematics of the
string theory too may be doable
equations it's not a solution yet just a
shortcut to the solution but once you
figure out how to solve it you can
transform the solution into our
three-dimensional space congratulations
you solve the mystery of the universe
and how it started
through the hologram but does that mean
we ourselves are living inside a
hologram and what would it be like to be
a hologram when you take a selfie you
lose some of the information about
yourself when you later look at the
picture you can't see the back of your
head the Holograms are designed to
preserve all of that information if you
experience the world in a holographic
way you could look at someone else's
skin and tell everything about their
organs what they ate for lunch
even their thoughts is it just me or
does that sound creepy the fundamental
laws of our universe from black holes to
the smallest particles to the laws of
our reality could be potentially
described with the help of the
holographic principle it doesn't
necessarily mean we live inside a
hologram but if we did we wouldn't be
able to tell the difference anyway
maybe time doesn't exist either but
that's a story for another what if